one of the big things that all startups
do is they lie to themselves over and
over and over mines faster mine's
cheaper mine's better mines this mines
that no it's not and the reason it's not
is because whoever it is you're
competing with it's not like they're
ignoring you
it's not like oh my goodness this guy
just started on Shopify in the startup
competition he's doing a million dollars
this year what was me I might as well
close up the doors what are they doing
I'm gonna copy what they're doing and
now you've got to stay ahead and so you
know you've got to be very careful as an
entrepreneur to be brutally honest with
yourself and those are some of the
things that you'll hear from me as a
mentor that you know know what you know
know what you don't know but you've got
to know your business better than
anybody I think the most important is
knowing your strengths and weaknesses
and knowing what you enjoy doing you
know if you look at it as a job you've
already lost it it's not going to be
your passion and you're going to count
the hours if you look at it as something
you love to do and then you know what
your strengths are then you can leverage
those strengths in your business and in
helping others and once you recognize
your weaknesses then you can work with
people that complement you I mean every
one of my businesses I've had a partner
who's very anal Martin Woodall Todd
Wagner I mean incredibly anal people
perfectionist because I'm a slob you
know I'm a big-picture think about
what's around the corner how is
technology gonna change things how can I
change you know this industry and you
know making sure that there's somebody
there to dot the i's cross the t's and
keep me in the bass lines Elm and you
know recognizing my weaknesses is just
as important as recognizing my strengths
and my core competencies and and you
know having a passion to do you just
watch two amazing clips with Mark Cuban
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]